the spookiest holiday of the year is
looking a little different this time due
to the covet 19 pandemic
orca mana joins us live from floyd land
park in the far northwest valley
where a special halloween event is
taking place and orca said you said that
you have a costume it's just not exactly
visible right
that's right sasha happy halloween to
you i am wearing a costume it might not
look like it but i'm actually the blue
power ranger
just for clarification if anyone was
asking i'm sure no one was but
i felt the need to say that again we are
out here at floyd land park where this
amazing event is going on here you can
see that because of the coronavirus is
actually a drive-through halloween event
when families can enjoy all the tricks
and treats right from their cars
now people pop their trunks and then
volunteers put goodie bags filled with
candy directly inside
so it's completely contactless there's
also a stage with music and halloween
decorations
and a lot of families who are trying to
figure out how to celebrate halloween
this year while we still deal with the
coronavirus
and this is the perfect way to do that
the event is being put on by the las
vegas city council and councilwoman
michelle fiore
fiori's coordinator tells us this is the
least they could do and also kids say
they're having a great time so i feel
like this is the best day in my life
because like best halloween because like
we're driving in the car
and even though we get little stuff it
doesn't matter because i'm still happy
always as i am
and this event started at five o'clock
so it has about half an hour to go it's
supposed to wrap up at seven but you can
see we got a whole line of cars
coming into this area of floyd land park
so it's definitely a celebration that's
worth taking the trip out here
and again it does wrap up at seven
o'clock so if you have any celebrations
and any
photos of your kids that are in their
costumes be sure to send them to us
at eight news now reporting live from
floyd lamb park tonight orca mana
8 news now